oh damn i think i could just like pop
pop
[Music]
hey guys henry golding here i am ready
to answer the internet don't forget
snake is out in
cinemas now who's more badass james bond
or jason bourne
bond it's gotta be classic classic
british hero
[Laughter]
if you were continuously getting
attacked by eagles one at a time
how many could you kill before they got
you oh
damn i think i could just like that
okay we'll get we'll probably let's say
what like five until they start like
scratching my eyeballs out would you
rather be a hair
hairless or never be able to cut your
hair
um never be able to cut your hair easy
man
i mean both guys get laid though who
would you want to represent you in a
trial by combat ico
waes he's in he's in snake guys he's
from the raid
this [ __ ] is like a bad ass like
his
he does like silat which is a southeast
asian martial art
it's like insane if you haven't seen uh
the raid one of the most
classic martial arts films like you will
ever find it's like insane
it's like he has to work his way up to
this building to like the bad guy are
they made in american bridge i think
that sucks
yeah yeah yeah definitely suck would you
rather
a burp the sound of a gong that
like loud [ __ ] sneeze the sound of a
bowling strike
sneeze the sound of a bowling strike i
mean it's kind of awesome
i mean yeah isn't it isn't it like a
such a
good sound like just i don't know
would you rather be half your heights or
double your weight
man that one's a tough one huh i gotta
say double the weight
yeah you could pull up yeah yeah you
know you can like put it in the right
places and kind of
get around the back and you know but the
height's an issue i don't know like half
the questions in the deck i've answered
the internet are about
your dick or getting hard or using it
make sure that that's never a problem
for you
go to getroman.com bar stool to get 50
off all your ed medicine make sure that
dick works can i have some free please
if every time you finish sex a song
played what song would you want it to be
what are your suggestions what do you
get a con i'm sorry
um jeff buckley hallelujah let's go
[Laughter]
marry [ __ ] kill brad pitt matthew
mcconaughey
channing tatum damn i'd marry matthew
mcconaughey how how
how [ __ ] cool was that guy that guy's
like he's unreal [ __ ] brad pitt
chad chan say i'm sorry dude
sorry man sorry he was in the last gia
show i know
i know i feel bad but that's the order
stay in there all right who would win a
fight
in their prime michael keaton or jon bon
jovi michael keaton for sure
that [ __ ] played batman like the
original og batman
like i don't think anyone's ever
answered bon jovi yeah yeah like
dude if he went against like jack
nicholson as like
that joke versus nicholson
he was a crazy [ __ ] in that film
jack nicholson
yeah would you rather relive your best
sports moment or your best sex moment
damn i haven't played like competitive
sports since i was
i must have been like 14. what was your
sport like
soccer um but we went to this
international
uh like under 12
soccer tournament in like amsterdam or
somewhere crazy
but we got third place with penalties
so it was like the greatest [ __ ]
moment of my life like i was just
bawling my eyes out so there's nothing
like winning
something in sports you can't i mean
it's like yeah
it's untouchable you're in the bedroom
and we're like we placed third place but
it was like still something
yeah that's but anyone's ever answered
sex it's always
always like yeah
unbelievable would you rather a throw up
any time someone says mcdonald's
be wear fedora for the rest of your life
and if anybody asks you about it you
have to say
i like the way it looks
i don't mind the fedora come on let's
bring it back
fedora fedora and the sand pants oh
i like the way it looks buddy deal with
it if you were murdered
who would be the most likely suspects
damn is that deviling guys
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] is like dodgy make
sure you put the plaque up
like where i die like where he hid my
body
you can turn any movie into a porno with
the same cast
from the movie which movie are you
picking damn
should we just go old school and just
see star wars you know every
everybody wants to see chewbacca get it
on come on
like this everybody wants to play with
chewbacca
disney's
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right big thanks for watching answer
the internet with henry golding snake
eyes comment below with who you want to
see do ati next
also make sure that you subscribe and
click the notification bell
down below